In 1985, two scientists from AT&T labs published
a paper on graphical perception and methods. The study
determined how accurately people read the visual cues that
are presented here. This resulted in a ranked list
of most accurate to least accurate visual cues. So
you can see that position is more accurate. Where
as hue is less accurate. What does accuracy mean
here? Well, in this case, it just means how
easily are people able to perceive the values in
your data set given the visual encoding that you've
chosen. You might wonder why saturation and hue are
considered inaccurate. Well, this is a great example. One should
be a little bit cautious when using color, hues
and saturation as visual cues. Like all aspects of
visual perception, we don't perceive color in an absolute
manner. For example, these are all different shades of gray.
When trying to compare and contrast them, it's difficult to
know which shades of gray correspond to exactly which values,
or just how much darker one shade of gray is
than another. For this reason, it's really hard for viewers of
your visualization to really know what a different shade of
gray might mean. How much bigger is one data point
than another? Because of this, you should be careful when
using color, hues and saturation, to encode information in your visualization.
This ranking up here is really a oversimplification of
how visualization works. So you should really use it as
a guide, rather than a definitive rule buck. Efficiency and
exactness are not always the goal of our visualization. Sometimes
color, saturation or color, hue or volume or area can
be really effective to communicate what we are trying to
tell the viewer. However it's good to know generally how
well people will be able to read different visual cues.